we're asked to look at the table below
from the information given is there a
functional relationship is there a
functional relationship between each
person and his or her height so a good
place to start just think about what a
functional relationship means now
there's definitely a relationship they
say hey if you're Joel you're 5/6 if
you're Nathan you're 411 if you're
Stuart you're 511 that is a relationship
now in order for it to be a functional
relationship for every instance or every
example of the independent variable you
can only have one example of the value
of the function for it so if you say if
this is a height function so if you say
height is the function height is a
function in order for this to be a
functional relationship no matter whose
name you put inside of the height
function you need to only be able to get
one value if there were two values
associated with one person's name it
would not be a functional relationship
so if I were to ask you what is the
height of if what is the height of
Nathan what is the height of Nathan well
you look at the table and say well
Nathan's height is 4 foot 11 Nathan is 4
foot 11 there are not two heights for
Nathan there is only one height and for
any one of these people that we can
input into the function there's only one
height associated with them so it is a
functional relationship and we can even
see that on a graph let's let me graph
that out for you so let's graph out so
let's see the highest height here is 6
foot 1 so if we start off with well we
don't have to start willis to me just
start at one foot two feet three feet 4
feet 5 feet 5 feet and 6 feet and then
if I were to plot the different names
the different people that I could put
into our height function we have I'll
just put the first letters of their
names we have Joel we have Nathan we
have Stuart we have
LJ and then we have thorak right there
so let's plot them so you have Joel Joel
height is five six so five six is right
about there then you have Nathan Nathan
tight let me do it in a different color
Nathan's height is 411 so Nathan's
height is 411 we will plot him right
over there then you have Stewart Stewart
ight is 511 so Stewart ight is 511 he is
pretty close to 6 feet so Stewart's
height
I made them like 6 feet let me make a
little Lord is 511 then you have LJ LJ
height is 5/6 so you have two people
with a height of five six but that's
okay as long as for each person you only
have one height and then finally tharok
is six foot one he's the tallest guy
here thorak is right up here at six foot
one so notice for any one of the inputs
into our function we only have one value
so this is a functional relationship now
you might say okay well isn't everything
a functional relationship no if I gave
you the situation if I also wrote here
let's say the table was like this and I
also wrote that Stuart Stuart is is five
foot is five foot three inches if this
was our table then Nolen we would no
longer have a functional relationship
because for the input of steward we
would have two different values if we
were to graph this we have steward here
at 511 and then all of a sudden we would
also have Stuart at five three now this
doesn't make a lot of sense so we would
plot it right over here so for Stuart
you would have two values and so this
wouldn't be a value of a valid
functional relationship because you
wouldn't know what value to give if you
were to take the height of if you were
to take the height of Stuart you in
order for this to be a function there
can only be one value for this you don't
know in this situation if I when I add
this whether it's 5 3 or 5 11 now this
wasn't the case so that isn't there and
so we know that the height of Stuart is
5 11 and this is a functional
relationship I think to some level
it might be confusing because it's such
a simple idea each of these values can
only have one height associated with it
that's what makes it a function if you
had more than one height associated with
it would not be a function